is making bakri bread for her family
they live in a village in western india
and every day she cooks all their meals
on a traditional cook stove it is
nothing more than sculpted clay around a
fire that is fueled by wood
nearly 3 billion people around the world
still depend on three stone fires and
traditional cook stoves like this unable
to afford or access cleaner forms of
energy
the burden of collecting and preparing
the fuel whether it's wood agricultural
waste or dung often falls on the women
and girls within a family and it is
women and their children whose health
suffers the most once these smoky
inefficient stoves are lit
recent research shows that nearly 4
million people die each year from
household air pollution caused by
combustion
that means that stove smoke is killing
more people than malaria tuberculosis
and hiv aids combined
research also shows that the smoke
doesn't stay inside the house drifting
out to be a major contributor to both
outdoor air pollution and climate change
to address these problems companies and
ngos are designing stoves that use less
wood and produce less smoke
a couple of years ago milan kolikari had
one of these improved cook stoves
installed in her house but she's not
using it
milan told me that the stove broke after
a couple of months and though there was
less smoke she felt like it used more
wood so she returned to her traditional
cook stove
even those who can afford cleaner fuel
such as gas can't always get it due to
government rationing and distribution
problems
this leads to a juggling act known as
stove stacking
emily theresa in the southern state of
tamil nadu alternates between a gas
stove a kerosene stove and outside she
uses a three stone fire to heat bath
water she also has a portable improved
cook stove which she bought through her
women's self-help group but it's usually
the last stove she turns to
given this reluctance to adopt improved
cook stoves some researchers say we
should help households leap directly to
proven clean technologies such as gas
and electric
while propane gas distribution remains
challenging there are promising
alternative efforts underway
for example local biogas digesters can
transform plants or manure into gas or
even electricity
and decentralized solar or wind power
systems can fuel clean efficient and
affordable induction cookers but these
projects remain small-scale so for now
stove designers will keep working on
improved cook stoves and sema and her
neighbors will keep stoking the smoky
fires that feed their families
for nature this is mira subramanian
you